عن عقد نحو 20 من اجهزه المخابرات الكبرى
في العالم اجتماعا سريا وذلك على هامش
اجتماعات حوار الامني المقام في سنغافوره
اجتماع سري لقاده اجهزه المخابرات في
سنغافوره وذلك على هامش اجتماعات حوار
الامني مصادر رويترز اكدت ان الاجتماع
يعقد سرا منذ عده سنوات فعلى الرغم من
الرفض الصيني لعقد لقاء عسكري مع امريكا
الا ان الاجتماع ناجح في ضم القوتين
العالميتين حيث اكدت المصادر حضور مديره
المخابرات الامريكيه افريل هاينز فيما لم
يعرف الممثل الصيني في الاجتماع اما
الممثل الروسي فكان الغائب الحاضر عن
الاجتماع
حيث نقشت الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه في
الاجتماع وفقا للمصادر المصادر قالت ان
الاجتماع لم يكن مخابراتيا بحثا بل كان
وسيله لتعزيز فهم النوايا خصوصا مع تزايد
التوترات في العالم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات